the most important reason why I do come  to Socrates because we need the blessing  from my family and my mom so we can get  engaged  without my family blessings my  relationship with Kimberly it is over  so I'm going to go and meet my mom  one-on-one first in order to help my mom  to understand who Kimberly is before she  met Kimberly tomorrow  Abuja  foreign  foreign  [Music]  I had a similar story like this when I  brought my eggs and I'm worried my mom  will not approve our relationship  because of what happened  Itachi  is  foreign  [Music]  foreign  to get engaged with Kimberly because I  think it's better if Kimberly and I will  be together because we are doing this  together so why should I ask her alone  but the sign is like a no-go area  foreign  [Music]  [Music]